your character in the movie steps on a
sea urchin at one point which is very
painful and I heard that that was
inspired by a real-life event that was
something that happened to you yes I
went away on a little vacation by myself
no partner no kids I'm just gonna take
two days and rest up and I paddled I
caught a little wave I jumped off I got
back on the board and as I put my foot
down I stepped on 45 sea urchin spines
there this long wait a minute it was one
sea urchin that had probably a gaggle of
family oh there was a whole bunch of
them block I think it was an orgy in the
ocean it was a sea urchin loving virgin
lovin and you you see and when I lifted
my foot out
it was a pin cushion of purple terror
okay yeah I described I don't know much
about sea urchin needles there barbed
there barbed so you can't pull them out
you kind of break them off right luckily
this big guy carried me to my car like
officer and a gentleman I couldn't I got
to where I was staying I had to crawl on
my hands and knees to like do anything I
called a neighbor and I said I think
alcohol and he said to porn your foot
and like no to drink right right away
right away alcohol that will kill the
pain pretty sure that's what the doctor
ordered there's this everyone always
says and I don't know if this is true
but that if someone urinates on a like
that that it immediately
it kills the poison is that true well I
put in the movie because I thought yeah
honey but this same thing happen to my
boyfriend except he got 2 or 3 and I
called poison control and before I could
get a word out my boyfriend's up don't
pee on it like what do you mean
everybody 600 people a day call and they
want to pee on don't pee on it
so it's the go-to thing but you're not
supposed to do it I've been I constantly
run around the beaches of Santa Monica
urinating on yeah I got started by one
pervy life I know it'll fix it really
it's a gunshot wound
[Laughter]